[Musik]
[Gelächter]
hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
kochwelt ich habe euch ja letzte Woche
schon gesagt dass ich euch mal zeige wie
ich meinen türkischen Reis mache so habe
ich den von meiner Mama gelernt und so
gebe ich jetzt euch weiter es gibt
natürlich wieder andere türkische Frauen
oder Männer die das vielleicht auch
anders machen aber so wird er halt bei
uns zu Hause gemacht und so schmeckt er
uns am besten
und für den Reis brauchen wir auch nur
ganz wenige Zutaten der Unterschied zu
dem normalen Reis den man vielleicht so
in Deutschland kennt ist dass es eben
kein quellreis ist den man einfach nur
mit Wasser aufkocht und dann quellen
lässt sondern der wird erst angebraten
und dann wird er mit Wasser aufgegossen
und da sind noch so kleine mininudeln
mit drin und die machen das Ganze eben
so richtig lecker ich zeige euch jetzt
einfach mal die Zutaten ich habe hier
einen Reis das ist jetzt ein typisch
türkischer oder mediterraner Reis das
ist ein Rundkornreis gibt z Beispiel von
baktad dann die ganz besondere Zutat
diese kleinen Nudeln die heißen chechie
und die braucht man beim türkischen Reis
mit dabei weil die vorher angebraten
werden ein Stück Butter da habe ich
jetzt etwa 20 g dann ungefähr ein halbes
Teeglas Öl das sind jetzt ungefähr 50 ml
und ich brauche Salz und ich werde jetzt
von den vom Reis etwa drei Gläser voll
nehmen wir sind heute fünf Erwachsene
und noch Samira und da müsst Ihr einfach
abstim und je nachdem wie viel Personen
ihr seid könnt ihr das dann mit so einem
Glas z.B abmessen wenn ich mit Murat und
Samira alleine bin nehme ich so fast
zwei Gläser voll und das reicht dann auf
jeden Fall für uns
alle und ich mache jetzt heute den Reis
weil es so eine Art Basic ist ich habe
ja schon ganz viele Hauptgerichte
gemacht und das ist so eine Basic die
nimmt man einfach zu jedem mediterranen
Hauptgericht mit dazu bei uns wird viel
Reis gegessen weniger Nudeln und das ist
jetzt so der Reis wie ich ihn eben
kennen also ich messe das jetzt einfach
ab und gibt es da ein so ein kleines
Glas
[Applaus]
rein ja das reicht auf jeden Fall also
sind jetzt drei gut gefüllte Gläser und
meine Mama hat mir das so beigebracht
dass man da jetzt Salz drauf gibt
richtig
viel sind etwa zwei
Esslöffel
und das übergießen wir jetzt mit heißem
gekochtem Wasser und zwar hilft es dann
dass da dann die Stärke aus dem Reis
eben rauskommt und der Reis später nicht
klebrig wird sondern dass man so den
Einzel die einzelnen reisstücke einfach
auf dem Löffel hat das ist ebenenso das
Besondere was meine Mama mir immer
beigebracht hat jetzt verrühre ich das
kurz und lass das so etwa 5 Minuten
stehen und werd dann abwaschen und
abgäßen und sieht es jetzt hier auch
ganz deutlich dieses Wasser ist jetzt
ganz trüb geworden weil einfach die
Stärke aus dem Reis jetzt im Wasser ist
und die wollen wir jetzt
wegwaschen deswegen habe ich jetzt hier
meinen
Sieb und schüttet das da
rein und jetzt übergieße ich das so
lange mit kaltem Wasser bis das Wasser
was unten rauskommt eben klar
ist
und
fertig und wenn ihr das dann habt gebt
ihr jetzt in eine heiße Pfanne das
Öl ich mE wenn ihr da jetzt weniger Reis
habt dann müsst ihr nürlich auch weniger
Öl und weniger Butter nehmen und da
kommen jetzt die Nudeln mit
rein sig wenn das sch nicht hat kann man
kann man da nicht irgendwie
spaghettinudel nehmen und die dann klein
machen und geht es nicht also es gibt ja
so ganz feine Nudeln die heißen doch
Fadennudeln und die kann man auch nehmen
also das habe ich auch mal gemacht da
hatte ich kein schch da und hat aber
Fadennudeln da das sind so ganz ganz
dünne Spaghetti und die kann man dann
einfach mit den Händen so ein bisschen
zerkrümeln dass sie klein werden und die
kann man dann auch nehmen also geht auch
dieses Röstaroma genau es geht ums
Röstaroma und da ist eigentlich egal man
könnt sogar wenn man will Sternchen
Nudeln nehmen also wenn man das z.B für
die Kinder schön haben will oder ABC
Nudeln und wir werden die jetzt einfach
ein bisschen anbraten oder fast
Frittieren so dass S einfach eine schöne
goldbraune Farbe
bekommen und kurz bevor sie goldbraun
werden gebe ich gleich noch die Butter
mit rein die kommt am Anfang nicht
gleich dazu damit sie einfach nicht zu
schnell
[Musik]
verbrennen
und die Butter gibt dem ganzen natürlich
noch mal so ein richtig schönes Aroma
Butter schmeckt ja
gut und das rundet dann das ganze so
ziemlich
ab so farblich sieht es jetzt so aus als
so ein karamelliger Ton so ein helles
Braun und jetzt kommt da der Reis mit
rein und jetzt wird es ganze
verrührt und ich brate den Reiz jetzt so
etwa eine Minute mit an und danach werde
ich den übergießen mit
Wasser und jetzt gebe ich noch das heiße
Wasser mit dazu ich gebe jetzt heißes
Wasser rein damit es einfach schneller
kocht und da sollte jetzt der Reis
richtig gut bedeckt
sein
so
wenn ihr euch nicht sicher seid wie viel
dann gebt da lieber erstmal etwas
weniger mit rein so dass der Reis
bedeckt ist und wir können später immer
noch dazu geben falls der Reis noch zu
hart ist ich gebe jetzt auch gleich das
Salz mit rein bei mir ist es jetzt etwa
so ein gehäfter
Teelöffel
so jetzt gebe ich den Deckel drauf und
schalte die Hitze auch runter auf etwa
zwei bei mir geht der Herr bis neun also
das ist so im unteren Bereich und so
lasse ich jetzt den Reis einfach garen
etwa 20 Minuten lang ihr müssten auf
jeden Fall kontrollieren falls ihr kein
Wasser mehr seht dann probiert einfach
mal vom Reis ob er schon durch ist und
ich zeige ihn euch dann einfach wenn er
fertig
ist mein Reis ist jetzt fertig und ich
habe ihn jetzt auch schon mal umgerührt
und ihr müsst da einfach mal probieren
wenn er noch zu hart ist gibt da einfach
noch ein bisschen Wasser mit dazu und
lasass den etwas länger garen aber so
ist er jetzt eigentlich richtig perfekt
und ich werde den jetzt hier anrichten
und entweder könnt ihr das direkt auf
den Teller geben oder in so eine Schale
rein und könnt es dann zu einem süßen
Türmchen
machen und dann gebt ihr das einfach auf
den Teller
drauf so und habt ein süßes
Türmchen und jetzt kann man da natürlich
was dazu servieren bei uns gibt's da
heute auch was dazu und ich werde es
jetzt allerdings für euch einfach mal so
lassen dass ihr das sehen könnt und der
Reis ist so richtig schön locker und
körnig und flockig kann ich euch auch
hier zeigen also der klebt halt nicht so
und ist ganz locker und ja Samira ist
den am liebsten mit bisschen Joghurt
oder mit Zitrone so mag ich den
eigentlich auch aber natürlich ist es ja
eigentlich meistens nur eine Haupt eine
Beilage zu einer Hauptspeise und das
Rezept gibt's dann zum Nachlesen auf
sis-blog.de aber die wichtigsten
Schritte habe ich euch hier in dem Video
schon gesagt weil es kommt ja einfach
drauf an für wie viele Personen ihr das
macht und eben je nachdem wie viel Reis
ihr dann benutzt müsst ihr dann auch
Wasser benutzen ich hoffe euch hat das
Video gefallen ich würde gerne wissen
was bei euch so die lieblingsbeilage ist
ist es Reis oder sind es Nudeln oder
vielleicht doch Kartoffeln ich mag
eigentlich alles ganz gerne und bei uns
gibt's es einfach abwechselnd und ich
wünsche euch auf jeden Fall noch einen
ganz guten appeetit und ganz viel Spaß
beim Nachmachen ich dekoriere das jetzt
hier noch schön spätze ist die beste
Beilage Spätzle bei ME Mann es gibt nur
Spätzle normalerweise nur Spätzle er ist
ja auch ein
Schwabe viel Spaß beim Nachmachen
[Musik]
tschüss